now you have testified that when you've
met with Muller at the Justice
Department you had that meeting that you
were surprised when he told you then
that he was not going to reach a
conclusion on obstruction yes rod and I
were both surprised by that did you ask
him look we need you to make it a
conclusion on this you should make a
conclusion I would I wouldn't say I
really pressed him on it I was
interested in his thinking on it and he
explained his position said he was still
thinking it through and and but I didn't
really press him nor did rod but you
left that meeting thinking that he
wasn't going to have a conclusion that's
right do you feel because he didn't do
that I mean did he fulfill his
responsibilities as Special Counsel if
you look at the regulations
it seems anticipate that you would get a
confidential report explaining why he
made a decision to either prosecute or
decline to prosecute he didn't do that
it seems to me right but on the other
hand he he did provide us of a report
and what he viewed to be the relevant
facts and that allowed us as the as the
leaders of the department to make the
decision what's the fundamental
difference why I mean he said that he
couldn't exonerate the president that he
looked at the evidences of possible
extraction
he couldn't exonerate the president if
he could he would have stated so you
looked at that evidence and you did I
mean what's the fundamental difference
between your view and his well I think
Bob said that he was not going to engage
in the analysis he was he was not going
to make a determination one way or the
other and he also said that he could not
say that the the president was clearly
did not violate the law which of course
is not the standard we use at the
department we have to determine whether
there is clear violation of the law and
so we applied the standards we would
normally apply we analyzed the law
and the facts and a group of us spent a
lot of time doing that and determined
that both as a matter of law many of the
instances would not amount to
obstruction as a matter of law as a
matter of law in other words we didn't
agree with the legal analysis a lot of
the legal analysis and the report it did
not reflect the views of the department
it was the views of a particular lawyer
or lawyers and so we applied what we
thought was the right law but then we
didn't rely on that we also looked at
all the facts tried to determine whether
the government could establish all the
elements and as to each of those
episodes we felt that the evidence was
deficient